hi everyone my name is Tamara chambers
and this is Tamara's never seen and
tonight I am finally watching Braveheart
hence the very heavy blue makeup I feel
like myself from the Wickerman review I
know that nothing about this film is
like accurate and historically but I've
heard that it's good it's the winner of
five Academy Awards including Best
Picture in 1995 these are the things I'm
saying like you don't know I just didn't
know I went to Edinburgh like two years
ago and it was by far the coolest and
most beautiful and tranquil and peaceful
and just weird place I've ever been I
want to move to Edinburgh or Glasgow one
of these days Mel Brooks though oh my
god Mel Gibson though what else has he
been in other than tabloid signs
I think signs is the only film I've ever
actually seen him in this is three hours
long though I don't do good with long
films and if it's not a historically
accurate that I'm just not gonna be
invested I'm gonna see them doing things
like why did you choose to do that and
so just like do it the way that it
happened Scotland's history is brutal
like you just make it the way well
complain goodbye goodbye and all right
let's do it
[Music]
you were wrong bitch I loved it
it was genuinely worth putting on all
this blue makeup before honestly I
really did not anticipate enjoying that
and what's stupid thing I'll be you
should just watch all of the Best
Picture awarded films like you should
just do that that's just like a good
thing to do obviously it didn't win Best
Best Picture because people were like oh
man it was long and boring but we feel
like it should be probably good because
it was wrong and you like about history
so that's what I thought it was I
thought it was just like long and people
were like oh well it's impressive so
they liked it it's the Best Picture
winner Tamara God obviously it wasn't
accurate even this is the language that
they were speaking in with so hilarious
I mean all this took place in the 1300
question mark I want to say that's when
all this went down so the language they
were using was clearly incorrect but I
mean other than that
it all seems pretty much like yeah that
could happen sure I'll buy it fine so
William Wallace is our main character
and his dad and brother died in battle
and all of a sudden this really cool
dude with a weird eye comes over named
Argyle great name and he's like I'm
gonna teach you how to fight how to
speak different languages I'm going to
educate you and that's that let's do it
and he's like I don't want to leave and
he's like well you didn't want your dad
died either did you
so happens and that's what I'm
talking about he didn't say happens
but like some of the language they use
it's pretty contemporary also all of Mel
Gibson's acting is incredibly
contemporary Keane though I will say did
act it really well
leaved what he was going through stuff
and I genuinely enjoyed him in the role
other than he took me out of it
sometimes because he was pretty
contemporary - learn how to use this
then I'll teach you how to use this I
got terribly excited Scottish accent
that I attempt terribly he's such a
badass when he returns and he's
knowledgeable and he's great with
fighting he's also great with his words
and he already is in love with someone
and he's got such confidence then the
woman that he's in love with and him
marry in secret because her parents
don't want her to marry him and I'm like
I love it it's romantic
you truly believe they're in love no the
little scamp's well kind of little I
never actually know how old he is
he always has looked so old to me he's
never aged but not in a good way cuz he
was always at like an old age it's in
the forehead lines and I have them too I
do the squint here and I'm always always
all the time in just frowning got those
lines I've got the middle lines
I just wrote Oh boobs and then later I
wrote Oh penises and but there's a lot
of body parts happening in this film and
I'm here for it the English are like
with the overlords of the Scots at this
time and the Scots want their freedom
they don't have it so that's like
basically the whole film is after this
one occurrence William Wallace is like
well let's go get our freedom then
freedom is like the whole thing so the
English guards are hanging out around
the camp where all the Scots are living
and they tried to rape the woman think
he just married and then she puts up a
great fight he like helps and like
knocks him out and then they take her
away
they kill her they just got married I
was not expecting that I really didn't
think they were gonna kill her I really
thought that she was gonna be like his
badass like side like wife the whole
side side
that's not a thing you know to me I
thought she was gonna be liked by his
side during it all and like the support
they move like not at all not even at
all she comes back in dreams sometimes
that's not so like you do Mel and the
men of the village kill all of the
guards and then they just go around and
they keep killing all of the guards
there's I want to say three different
groups cleanse all state groups in in
all of Scotland's at this time and they
are not getting along and that's pretty
much why they have it United you take
your freedom back it's cuz they're
always fighting within themselves
throughout the film that unites and then
they don't you know the unite they don't
unite then they're not uniting is why it
like William Wallace was captured the
whole thing's a lot of drama y'all are
grown ass men get along just oh the
famous blue face speech they may take
our lives but they wouldn't terrible
Scottish I honestly his wasn't great
they may take our lives but they will
never take our lovely blue makeup a lot
of penises and butts in this scene it's
a big fight scene lots of penises and
Buzz which is not what I was expecting I
honestly did not expect under the kilt
for there to be nothing I was said I
always thought there was something the
fight is incredible though it's long and
it's impressive that's what she said
that's what everyone said honestly we
all said it there's a bunch of fights
Scotland's not uniting so William
Wallace is like well I'm just gonna
invade England's then because y'all it
turns into this whole thing where the
Scots was like okay we are going to
unite and it's a lie and they turn a
William Wallace into the King of England
gets just together Scots I'm
talking about you f scott Fitzgerald and
you Scott T Star Trek and
other famous Scots I am I love this line
that he says he says I'm so afraid give
me the strength to die well and he looks
truly afraid he the way he says it he
thinks like his voice is quivering while
he's being tortured he yells freedom out
instead of mercy if he yells mercy but
we won't just give him a quick death and
in the end he sees his wife that died in
the audience of people watching him
being publicly executed and then you
find out that the Scots did unite and
then they won their freedom it's like
well this little leg guys it's just a
little late my mom loves this movie it's
a long one and definitely has sad
moments but there's an epic quality to
it that I think you'll be mesmerized by
yes and I think that comes with the Best
Picture thing like that's just something
that I should not be skeptical about
best pictures I saw Shawshank Redemption
for the first time I think four years
ago well before Tamra's never seen but
it was one that I was hanging out
friends and they were like you've never
seen let's just watch it it's so damn
good I was like oh it sounds so loooong
like I just don't think I'm into amaura
and I was mesmerized it's incredible
obviously and so the fact that I wait so
long to see things like sad also Mel
Gibson was a damn good actor too bad
he's crazy you know what I could have
said that better myself I do truly love
God ish history I think
I lived anywhere other than Chicago it
would be Scotland and I was really into
seeing a movie about the history of it
even though I know none of it is true
I've been putting this one off for so
long this in Citizen Kane are the two
that I just like them oh and Godfather
oh my god I do not think I'm gonna like
Godfather it just doesn't sound fun I
know it's gonna be good or whatever
everybody doesn't sound fun
go back to the little lego movie with a
volleyball scene in Top Gun just back
thank you so much for watching I will
see you guys all next week they're after
me lucky charm known as Irish
[Music]
[Applause]
you